How do I act so well? What I do is I pretend to be the person I'm portraying in the film or play. Yeah. You're confused. No. It's perfectly simple. Case in point, Lord of the Rings. Peter Jackson comes from New Zealand and says to me, Sir Ian, I want you to be Gandalf the wizard.
我演戏怎么演得这么好？我所做的就是假装自己是电影或戏剧中扮演的那个人。没错。你困惑了。不，这非常简单。举个例子，《指环王》。彼得·杰克逊从新西兰过来对我说：“伊恩爵士，我想让你扮演巫师甘道夫。”
And I say to him, you are aware that I am not really a wizard. And he said, yes, I am aware of that. What I want you to do is to use your acting skills to portray the wizard for the duration of the film. So I said, okay. And then I said to myself, hmm, how would I do that? And this is what I did. I imagined what it would be like to be a wizard
我对他说：“你知道我并不是真的巫师吧。”他说：“是的，我知道。我希望你利用你的表演技巧，在电影拍摄期间扮演好这个巫师。”所以我说：“好吧。”然后我对自己说：“嗯，我该怎么做呢？”这就是我所做的：我想象自己成为一名巫师会是什么样子，
and then I pretended and acted in that way on the day. And how did I know what to say? The words were written down for me in a script. How did I know where to stand? People told me. Alright.
然后我就在那一天假装并以那种方式表演。我怎么知道该说什么？台词都写在剧本里了。我怎么知道该站在哪里？别人告诉我的。好吧。
This is the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. I'm here with Andy Philpo, a big film guy and designer. We're going to talk about some new technology. But first, he's going to come on and apologize for the horrible accusations against him. And I don't want to get too much into that yet, but it is definitely the reason that Galaxy's Edge got shut down at Disney World. So I'll let you take it from there. Wow, thanks for that great intro, Joel. My bosses are going to be so glad that I agreed to come on the podcast now. Um, I, I remember, you know, Matthew, like our friend from college. And I remember, uh, like watching the, uh, what is it?
这是Taproot Therapy Collective播客。我和安迪·菲尔波（Andy Philpo）在一起，他是一位资深电影人和设计师。我们将讨论一些新技术。但首先，他要为针对他的可怕指控道歉。我不想太深入讨论那个，但这绝对是迪士尼乐园的“银河边缘”被关闭的原因。所以，我就让你从那里开始吧。哇，谢谢你这么棒的开场白，乔尔。我的老板们现在一定会很高兴我同意参加这个播客了。嗯，我，我记得，你知道，马修，就像我们大学的朋友。我记得，呃，就像看那个，呃，是什么来着？
Jerry Seinfeld. Who's the actor that plays Kramer? What's like, what's that guy's name? Um, Michael Richards, Michael Richards. Yeah. Michael Richards was apologizing on Letterman via tele teleconference while Jerry Seinfeld was the guest and Jerry Seinfeld was just screaming at the crowd. Like, stop laughing. It's not funny. I mean, I've seen it happen a couple of times in my life but when
杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）。演克莱默（Kramer）的那个演员是谁？那家伙叫什么名字？嗯，迈克尔·理查兹（Michael Richards），迈克尔·理查兹。对，迈克尔·理查兹在莱特曼（Letterman）节目上通过远程会议道歉，当时杰瑞·宋飞是嘉宾，而杰瑞·宋飞只是对着人群尖叫。就像，别笑了。这不好笑。我的意思是，我这辈子见过几次这种情况，但当你
you're a stand-up comedian on a stage yelling at the audience stop laughing it's not funny like does something not go off in your brain being like oh this isn't this isn't working it's peak ironic comedy yeah unless you're eric andre like you're doing something wrong when you're yelling at the crowd to stop laughing i don't know so um we've talked a little bit about uh filmmaking before you know you're more kind of on the technical end of of stuff and um i was hoping that this would kind of turn into like a filmmaking uh series we had a couple guests uh chris rogers who um wrote halt and catch fire and paper girls and a couple shows that i like is going to come on we'll record that next week i don't know when it'll go out and i i don't want
是一个站在舞台上的单口喜剧演员，对着观众大喊“别笑了，这不好笑”，难道你的大脑里没有某种东西会跳出来说：“哦，这行不通，这简直是讽刺喜剧的巅峰”吗？是的，除非你是埃里克·安德烈（Eric Andre），否则当你对着人群大喊别笑时，你肯定做错了什么。我不知道，所以，嗯，我们之前谈过一点关于电影制作的事，你知道，你更多是在技术层面，嗯，我希望这能变成一个电影制作系列。我们有几位嘉宾，克里斯·罗杰斯（Chris Rogers），他写了《奔腾年代》（Halt and Catch Fire）和《纸女孩》（Paper Girls），还有几部我喜欢的剧，他会来参加，我们下周录制。我不知道什么时候会播出，而且我不想
to like say who they are because people definitely have the right to like not come on a show like this which is probably a waste of their time you know but um they sent a couple of different emails to people that are trying to see if we can make it work with scheduling and whatever of like little things. So I don't know, maybe we'll get a critical mass of some Hollywood people, but I thought it'd be fun to talk about the way that you're applying technology because it is so different.
说出他们是谁，因为人们绝对有权选择不参加这样的节目，这可能是在浪费他们的时间，你知道，但是，嗯，他们给试图看看我们能否协调日程安排的人发了几封不同的电子邮件，诸如此类的小事。所以我不知道，也许我们会聚集一批好莱坞人士，但我认为谈谈你应用技术的方式会很有趣，因为它太不同了。
And even though some of the things like you had talked a little bit about Disney's projects, but even though like what you're doing is like way more state-of-the-art i guess than even you know the blue screen 90s stuff it feels older world like it feels like the soundstage you know 70s type filmmaking that i like more than what we ever we've done for the past 15 years well the psychology of that i think is ripe for discussion and i'll turn that over to you yeah uh so yeah i no longer work at disney i've moved on to some other things but of course they're the big touchstone for like visual effects and production and things like that so now i do a
尽管你谈到了一些关于迪士尼项目的事情，但即使你所做的比90年代的蓝幕技术更先进，它也感觉像是旧世界，感觉像是70年代的那种摄影棚电影制作，我比我们过去15年所做的更喜欢那种风格。嗯，我认为这背后的心理学值得讨论，我会把它交给你。是的，呃，所以我不再在迪士尼工作了，我已经转向其他事情了，但当然，它们是视觉特效和制作等方面的重要标杆，所以现在我做了
lot of like uh concert design live events things like that um but the the technology that you're talking about, the sort of what gets labeled in the industry is like, in camera VFX, right now is you're absolutely right. It's like a super old technology, because the oldest versions of it was like you hung up a big rear projection screen behind the like James Bond car. And then you rolled your like B roll of the California like countryside behind it and like that was how you got the effect of someone driving and so there's been a confluence of technologies in the last say 10 uh 10 years maybe uh that have made it possible to kind of like bring that sort of in-camera effect back to modern production paradigms
很多像演唱会设计、现场活动之类的事情，但是你谈到的那种技术，也就是行业内所说的“片场内视觉特效”（in-camera VFX），现在你是完全正确的。这是一种超级古老的技术，因为它的最早版本就像是在詹姆斯·邦德的汽车后面挂一个巨大的背投屏幕。然后你在后面播放加州乡村的B卷素材，这就是你获得某人开车效果的方式。所以，在过去，比如说10年里，技术的融合使得将那种片场内效果带回现代制作模式成为可能。
um and they are uh very specifically and it's and it's interesting because of the the relationship to the other like advancements in technology we've seen but uh the first one is um very like low uh pixel pitch led tile right so you can have lots of that like your tv is like super high res we can make that at like a wall-sized scale right like everyone's seen the documentary about the mandalorian with the big led wall i don't know that everyone has if you don't mind uh like telling us a little bit about what that technology looks like on a set because i think the hostility from film nerds a lot of people hear technology and they say, like, get that out of my movie.
嗯，它们是，呃，非常具体的，而且很有趣，因为它们与我们看到的其他技术进步有关，但第一个是，嗯，非常低像素间距的LED面板，所以你可以拥有很多那种，就像你的电视是超高分辨率的，我们可以把它做成墙壁大小，对吧？每个人都看过关于《曼达洛人》的大型LED墙的纪录片。我不知道每个人都看过，如果你不介意的话，呃，告诉我们一点那种技术在片场看起来是什么样的，因为我认为电影极客们有很多敌意，很多人听到技术就会说：“把它从我的电影里拿走。”
Like, I don't want, you know, episode one of Star Wars. I want the original trilogy or whatever. And they think of people running around green screen where there's no reference point. And, you know, basically thousands of engineers making a movie instead of a filmmaker. But what we've gone back to is a little bit more like the old world,
就像，我不要《星球大战》第一部那种。我要原版三部曲之类的。他们想到的是人们在绿幕前跑来跑去，没有参考点。而且，你知道，基本上是成千上万的工程师在制作电影，而不是电影制作人。但我们回归的是更像旧世界的东西，
old Hollywood. Yeah, so what that technology is, the touchstone that everyone thinks about with extended reality sets in camera VFX, these are the buzzwords that people use for it. But essentially what it is, it's a huge LED wall, like you would see at a concert. Does it curve? Is it like a dome, wall like you would see at like a concert curve like is it like a dome like an imax thing uh it it can be flat but the one specifically for mandalorian is a curved
老好莱坞。是的，所以那种技术，每个人想到扩展现实（XR）片场、片场内视觉特效时想到的标杆，这些是人们使用的流行语。但本质上，它是一面巨大的LED墙，就像你在演唱会上看到的那样。它是弯曲的吗？它像圆顶吗？像你在演唱会上看到的墙那样弯曲吗？像IMAX那种圆顶吗？呃，它可以是平的，但专门用于《曼达洛人》的那种是弯曲的
uh led surface uh and then they do like a handful of tiles overhead to make like kind of a ceiling but those are those are typically just a flat plane that's kind of just capturing some of the sky effect um and then you're still getting the ambient lighting that changes the way that the camera you know light bounces off the actors and all that stuff that right and that's look like they're real yeah so and that's really the big difference right and that's the advantage over something like green screen, where, you know, you see somebody on a green screen set and you can tell almost immediately because the shadows on their faces. Everything looks gray. There's that under contrasted like.
LED表面，然后他们在头顶做了一些面板来形成某种天花板，但那些通常只是一个平坦的平面，只是捕捉一些天空效果，然后你仍然会得到环境光，它改变了摄像机捕捉到的光线，你知道，光线从演员身上反射出来等等，对吧？看起来就像他们是真的。是的，所以这确实是最大的区别，对吧？这就是它相对于绿幕的优势，你知道，你在绿幕片场看到某人，你几乎可以立即分辨出来，因为他们脸上的阴影。一切看起来都是灰色的。有一种对比度不足的感觉。
And typically, if you look very closely, you can see the little hint of the green like back reflectance on whatever side is facing the uh the chroma uh backdrop behind them whereas with the led wall your light is the reflectance of whatever the environment is which is much closer to real life and that's something that like you've talked about in especially in the like healing the modern soul uh the way that intuition kind of picks up whether or not something feels real based on those like micro perceptions uh we basically before we think about it we already know if it we like it or not or if it's real or not exactly and it's like there's there's like subtle things that like you don't look for unless you know to look for them but as a designer like that's your whole world is like trying to pick up on those things before the audience does and correcting for them but as a designer like that's your whole world is like trying to pick up on
通常，如果你仔细看，你可以在面向他们身后的色度背景的任何一侧看到一点点绿色反射的痕迹，而使用LED墙，你的光线就是环境的反射，这更接近现实生活。这就是你在《治愈现代灵魂》中谈到的，直觉如何根据那些微观感知来判断某事是否感觉真实。基本上，在我们思考之前，我们就已经知道我们是否喜欢它，或者它是否真实。完全正确，就像有一些微妙的事情，除非你知道去寻找，否则你不会注意到。但作为一名设计师，你的整个世界就是试图在观众发现之前捕捉到这些东西并进行修正。但作为一名设计师，你的整个世界就是试图在观众发现之前捕捉到这些东西并进行修正。
those things before the audience does and correcting for them so that that technology of the led wall being able to create this environment and then the corollary one is the advances in real-time graphics the ability to create photo reel or a near photo reel real-time environments that you can generate on the fly that are tracking things like the camera movement in the physical world correlated to a camera in the virtual environment so that as you pan the camera across the performer the camera and the led wall is also moving and moving your scenery with it um and you can do those kinds of things in real time in a way that feels much closer to how it would look if you were shooting
所以，LED墙能够创造这种环境的技术，以及随之而来的实时图形技术的进步，即能够即时创建照片级或近乎照片级的实时环境，你可以动态生成这些环境，并跟踪物理世界中的摄像机运动，将其与虚拟环境中的摄像机相关联，这样当你平移摄像机穿过表演者时，摄像机和LED墙也在移动，并随之移动你的场景。嗯，你可以以一种感觉更接近你在某处实地拍摄时看起来的样子来实时完成这些事情，而不是像绿幕那样，有人必须放置跟踪器，并在后期制作中进行物理移动。我们现在在拍摄时就在摄像机中捕捉所有这些，这在创建这些东西的速度以及能够创建它们的保真度上都是一个巨大的飞跃。
on location somewhere as opposed to the green screen where it's like someone's got to place trackers and like physically move in post-production we're now capturing all of that in the camera as the shot is being done um and it's just such a huge jump in the the speed at which you can create those things and also the fidelity at which you're able to to create them well and there's almost like in the in the prequel trilogy that a lot of people didn't like there's almost the exact same scene at one point um in the sequel trilogy that I think people definitely liked the technique the way it looked at least you know more but there's like like Obi-Wan is in the bubble cockpit of a ship and there has to be like a laser blast goes by and then he has to
嗯，而且在很多人不喜欢的《星球大战》前传三部曲中，几乎有完全相同的场景，在后传三部曲中，我认为人们绝对更喜欢这种技术，至少看起来是这样，你知道，更多。但是，就像欧比旺在飞船的球形驾驶舱里，必须有一个激光束经过，然后他必须
react to it but the way that they're making it in the prequel trilogy, which doesn't really work or something feels wrong is that the script has to say reacts to laser blast. So, you know, Elon McGregor has to go, Oh, and look up. And then an animator has to go back in at about the same time that he looks
做出反应，但他们在前传三部曲中制作它的方式，感觉不太对劲，或者有什么地方不对，是因为剧本必须写“对激光束做出反应”。所以，你知道，伊万·麦克格雷格（Ewan McGregor）必须说“哦”，然后抬头看。然后动画师必须在他抬头看的同时回去制作这个爆炸。但这些事情之间没有真正的联系。对。而当奥斯卡·伊萨克（Oscar Isaac）在X翼战机的驾驶舱里时，你知道，在另一部电影里，他坐在屏幕前，有声音和光线实时配合，所以你看到他注意到激光束经过，
up and make this blast. But there was no real connection between those things. Right. And when Oscar Isaac's in the X-Wing cockpit, you know, and the other one, he's sitting there on a screen with you know and the other one he's it's sitting there on a screen with the sound and the light in real time so you see him notice the laser blast go by
击中某物，爆炸，抬头看，这并不是一种人为的惊喜，或者你知道，电影的各个部分之间有真正的联系，我认为这就是人们批评2000年代初和2010年代技术的地方，即存在这种脱节，东西是在几周或几个月的时间里制作出来的，并以一种并不真正奏效的方式合成在一起。是的，而且感觉不连贯，因为表演者不知道他们到底在对什么做出反应，而创作者，你知道，在后期制作中加入这些东西的技术艺术家，不得不处理这种预先录制好的反应，而
hit something explosion look up in a way that is not a manufactured surprise or you know there's an actual connection between the parts of the film which i i think is like what people criticize about um technology of like the early 2000s and you know 2010s was that there was this disconnect where things were being made you know weeks and months apart and and synthesized together in a way that didn't really work and yeah and it feels disjointed because the the performers don't know exactly what it is that they're reacting to um and the creators you know the technical artists that are putting that in and post are having to like work with this like pre-canned sort of reaction whereas
你可以在更现代的虚拟制作环境中实时处理这些事情。另一个你现在可以做而那个时代做不到的伟大例子，实际上是他穿的曼达洛人盔甲。那是那种明亮的、超反光的泡沫。它会反射绿幕。是的，你只能在曼达洛人的LED墙环境中做到这一点，但能够实现这种效果真是太酷了，而且不需要去外景地或建造复杂的布景，因为那是该剧令人印象深刻的事情之一，也是他们能够实现所有这些的预算。
you can kind of like you know work with those things in real time uh in more of a modern virtual production environment another like great example of like things that you can do now that you couldn't do in that era is actually the Mandalorian armor that he wears. It's all that bright, super reflective foam. It'd be reflecting green screen. Yeah, you can only get away with that in the Mandalorian LED wall environment, but it's such a cool effect to be able to achieve and without having to go on location or like build an elaborate set because that's one of the things that was really impressive for that show was also the the budget on which they were able to achieve all of that
是的，10年前这会贵10倍或20倍。嗯，当你试图跑过一个巨大的布景，并进行那种J.J.艾布拉姆斯风格的20分钟介绍，他们在躲避飞船上的洞的同时解释世界是如何运作的。我的意思是，这其中有一些引人入胜的东西，但我有点喜欢这种布景的写作方式，它迫使写作回归到几乎像戏剧一样，
yeah would have been 10 or you know 20 times as expensive 10 years ago well and when you can do anything when you're trying to run through a giant set and have a JJ Abrams style, 20 minute introduction where they're dodging a hole in the ship while they're explaining how the world works. I mean, there's something about that that is compelling, but I kind of like how the writing for the set has forced writing to go back to almost like plays,
你知道，你让尤达（Yoda）在沼泽里和卢克（Luke）谈了很长时间，而前传三部曲中没有那样的场景，它总是成千上万件事的巨大旋风。是的，你知道，为了掸掉我戏剧史的灰尘，这有点像对“地点统一”的渴望与那种横扫一切的歌剧布景设计之间的区别，在那里你会有一层又一层的背景，他们会把这些精心绘制的、巨大的风景画飞入，而不是基本上整部戏都发生在一个地点，在一段连续的时间内。这些只是在过去几年中流行和不流行的不同哲学，但我们现在正处于另一个周期中，因为可用的技术驱动了你想讲的故事以及你想如何讲它的创意。而且我不喜欢那样说，对吧？技术永远不应该是
you know, you're having Yoda talk to Luke in the swamp for a long time, whereas there's no scene like that in the swamp for a long time whereas there's no scene like that in the prequel trilogy it's always just a huge whirlwind of a million things and yeah it's it you know you're it's uh to to dust off my theater history for a second it's a little bit like the uh the difference between the desire for like unity of place versus uh the like sweeping versus the sweeping opera set design where you'd have backdrop after backdrop that they would just
摇动故事之尾的狗。但有时在探索中，你会发现利用你现有的工具讲一个更好的故事的机会。嗯，这就是我的问题。就像很多人，如果你说你在科技和戏剧、电影行业工作，他们听到技术就会想到
fly in of these really elaborately painted, massive scenic pieces versus having an entire play basically that takes place in one location over one contiguous span of time. And those are just different philosophies uh that have have fallen in and out of fashion over the years but it's like we're in another cycle of that right now as we as the technology available drives some of the creative of the the story that you want to tell and how you want to tell it and and i i don't like to say it that way, right? Like the tech should never be the tail
萨姆·奥特曼（Sam Altman）说：“好吧，我们甚至不再需要演员了，我们只是通过生成式AI生成视频。”你知道，或者他们想到无尽的蓝幕，你知道，他们想到《霍比特人》电影中无休止的特效列表，没有灵魂，但它一直持续下去。他们认为，好吧，技术是坏的，我的意思是，我认为电影中的技术是不可避免的。关键是怎么用？嗯，我的意思是，你能谈谈这个吗？或者你对那些对技术有负面反应的人有什么看法？所以我总是非常，我可能对AI及其当前化身持有的观点比很多人更中立。到目前为止，我的经验是，对于很多创意人员来说，如果他们想使用它，它是工具箱中的另一个工具，
wagging the dog of the story. But sometimes in exploration, you find opportunities to tell a better story with the tools that you have available to you. Well, and that's my question. It's like a lot of people, if you say that you're in tech and theater, you know, movies, they hear technology and they think
特别是现在，因为它还不完美，而且在我看来，也许永远无法在风格上创造出
of sam altman saying well we're not even going to have actors anymore we're just you know going to have generated video through generative ai you know or they think of the the endless blue screen you know they think of the the like you know just unending litany of effects in the Hobbit movie where there's like no soul, but it just goes on and on. And they think, okay, tech is bad, which I mean, technology, I think in movies is inevitable. It's how's, how's it used? Um, I mean, can you speak to that or what do you, somebody has a negative reaction to. So I'm always very, I probably have one of the more neutral opinions on like AI and its current incarnation relative to a lot of people out there. And so far as like my experience with it has been that it's another tool in the toolkit for a lot of like creatives to use if they want to uh especially as it is right now because it's not perfect and it doesn't in my opinion and and maybe never will uh be able to create stylistically the
人类那样的方式，你知道，因为它都是基于我们所做的事情进行训练的，它是基于过去进行训练的。是的，是的，所以它永远无法直觉地预见未来，至少在当前的化身中是这样，对吧？未来10年、20年里，也许它会做到这一点。我不可能知道。但现在，我认为有趣的一点是，这也是我感兴趣想听听你的看法的地方，因为它是基于过去训练的，
same way that a human does you know because it is all sort of like trained on what we do and it's trained on the past yeah yeah so it'll never be able to intuit the future, at least in this current incarnation, right? Like there's a world 10, 20 years from now where maybe it does that. And I can't possibly know. But right now, I think something that it's interesting with, and this is actually something I'm interested to hear your take on is that like, because it's trained on the past,
因为它基于自互联网诞生以来人类输入的大量原始数据的印记。就像，它是否让我们能够利用我们的集体潜意识，借用荣格（Jung）的一个术语，向我们展示一些我们可能无法通过自己对想法的迭代和发展而得出的东西？我可以去输入一些我想到的东西到一个像Midjourney
because it's trained on this sort of like imprint of so much raw data that has been input by humanity since the trained on the past, because it's trained on this sort of like imprint of so much raw data that has been input by humanity since the dawn of the internet. It's like, does it kind of allow us to tap into our collective unconscious to, to borrow a term from Jung and, and show us things that maybe we wouldn't have arrived at, you know, from our own sort of iteration and development of an idea, right. I can go type in something I've thought about to a program like mid journey
或ChatGPT这样的程序，说：“给我画一张这可能看起来是什么样的图片。”它可能会给我十几个我从未考虑过的结果，除了让AI给我提供一些东西之外。如果我感知的隧道视野只沿着这一条特定的路径走，现在我有一系列其他想法，我至少可以作为设计师去考虑并做出反应，说：“这符合我的愿景吗？”
or, or chat GBT and say, draw me a picture of what this might look like. And it might give me a dozen results that I never would have considered other than like asking the, you know, the AI to like sling some things at me. If my tunnel vision of my perception was only going down this one specific path. Now I've got an array of other ideas that I can at least consider and react to as a designer and say, does this speak to my vision?
还是完全偏离了轨道？这两种反应对于创意过程都非常有用。为什么我认为这就是关键，我的意思是，我认为它能够创建像Pinterest板一样的东西，或者给你八个布景设计，然后让你选择你想要的那个，你知道，进行头脑风暴，这可能很好，因为我的意思是，你的梦是基于过去训练的，对吧？就像荣格谈到梦是一种思考过去的方式，让我们根据以前发生的事情来预测未来，我们正在思考可能发生的事情。
Or is this totally off base? And either of those responses is very useful for the like creative process why i think that's it i mean i think that like its ability to create something like a pinterest board or to give you eight designs for a set and then let you pick the one that you were wanting you know to brainstorm is probably is probably good because i mean your dreams are trained on the past right like jung talks about how dream is something it's a way of thinking about the past that lets us anticipate the future based on what's happened before we're thinking about what might happen um so you know like a lot of times like
所以，你知道，很多时候，AI，尤其是视觉方面的东西，它是在做梦，它是在与模式进行自由联想，这就是它的一些怪异之处的原因，因为互联网上有太多的狗的照片。一些早期版本被过度训练以识别狗的脸。所以他们会把狗脸放在，你知道，胡须图案里，或者任何它可能看到图案的地方。所以，我的意思是，对我来说，这太有趣了，因为你正在进入我认为关于精神病和那种深层大脑的整洁的东西，但我想要，把那个作为一个
ai is you know especially the visual stuff it is dreaming it's like free associating with patterns um which is what makes some of its weirdness that it has like an over, because there's so many pictures of dogs on the internet. Some of the early versions were like over-trained to spot faces of dogs. So they would like put dog faces inside of like, you know, beard pattern or just places where it might see a pattern. So, I mean, to me, that's so interesting because you're getting into this stuff that I think is neat about, you know, psychosis and, you know, the, the kind of deep brain, but I want to, to, to put a pin on that as a,
简短的观点。就像，我认为很多对我来说很有趣并且澄清了我从未理解的旧模式的脑科学是，大脑并没有真正处理太多东西。那并不是理解认知的关键。一直在发生大量的处理。所以意识更多的是一个过滤器。它更多的是“为了专注于这个，我忽略了什么？”你知道？而且像精神分裂症的感觉门控理论，很多这些较新的理论都在说，好吧，当这些认知问题发生时，并不是说创造了一些以前不存在的东西。而是有些东西没有被过滤掉，而本应该被过滤掉。
as a short point. Like, I think that a lot of the newer brain science that is interesting to me and clarifies things that never understood about the old pattern is that there's so much it's the brain isn't really processing. Like that's not really the key to understanding cognition. There's so much processing happening. So are all the time. Consciousness is more of a filter. It's more of what am I ignoring to focus on this, you know? And that things like the sensory gating theory of schizophrenia, a lot of these newer theories are saying like, well, when these problems with cognition happen, it's not that something
所以那些AI本质上是过滤器，它们正在经历大量别人以前做过的事情，这使得它本质上不是原创的，你知道，对吧？然后它们正在研究我们如何以一种反映你要求我做的事情的方式结合这些东西，这是一个很好的头脑风暴方式。道格·拉什科夫（Doug Rushkoff）说，他写了这些小说，然后他改进了这些小说，因为他问AI：“嘿，角色在所有这些情况下会做什么？”而在它说要做他已经做过的事情的每一个地方，他说：“那不好，那不好。”而且最终他永远不会发现他写作中那30%有点懒惰的套路。如果不是电脑说：“好吧，为什么他们不这样做？”而这就是他想出来的。所以我认为这也像电影制作的很大一部分是并置奇怪的流派，
is being created that didn't used to be there. It's that there's something not being filtered out that should be and and um and so those ais are essentially filters they're going through a ton of what has been done by somebody else before which what makes it inherently not original you know right and then they're looking at how can we combine these in a way that reflects what you're asking me to do which is a great way to brainstorm um doug reshkoff said that you know he wrote these novels and then he improved the novels because he asked an ai hey what does a character do in all of these situations and everywhere where it said to do what he had done he said that's not a good that's not that's not good like and that it
你知道，很多真正有影响力的东西就像是把两个非常奇怪的想法放在一起，然后把它们结合起来创造一个新东西，太空西部片之类的。对。所以我可以看到它对这样的事情很有帮助，因为它知道这是什么，它知道那是什么，你结合它，然后它给你关于如何制作布景或如何做类似事情的有趣想法。也许吧。我发现它非常擅长的一种东西是那种风格转换，你知道，就像你把
ended up he but he never would have spotted those 30% of the tropes that were kind of lazy in his writing. If it wasn't a computer saying, well, why don't they do this? And that's what he had come up with. So I think like that also so much of filmmaking is like juxtaposing weird genres,
某种东西输入进去，某种图像，然后你说：“用这些不同的风格向我展示这个。”对吧？或者“在《星球大战》中向我展示这个”，你知道，或者《变形金刚》或《捉鬼敢死队》，或者无论范式可能是什么，但它是因为它知道所有这些东西，它知道所有的流行文化参考，它可以做这种有趣的，你知道，那里有一个真正的兔子洞，但你可以调节一堆设置，然后得到一定量的你的输入与AI的对比，你知道，某种对你给定的图像或想法的描摹，然后让它吐出一些“好吧，这可能看起来像这样”。你知道，嗯，对于视觉特效，我可以看到它是一个很好的抛光剂，当你
you know, like a lot of the really influential stuff is like getting two really weird ideas and then putting them together to make a new thing, a space Western or something. Right. and so i could see it being helpful for something like that because you've got it knows what this is it knows what that is you combine it and then it's giving you interesting ideas about how to make a set or how to how to do something like that maybe yeah something i've found that it's really good at is that kind of like stylistic transposition you know where it's like you have, you know, something that you feed into
得到你想要的效果的大致轮廓时，它会进去清理光线，或者清理水的熔融特性，或者魔法咒语反射周围的光线，不需要成百上千的工程师团队去逐一视觉修改每件事，但你仍然需要拥有愿景的人类元素，我认为AI做不到。是的，绝对可以区分它自己的噪音，你知道。是的，而且我绝对认为它现在所处的位置，我永远不会考虑将其用于没有任何人类干预的完全成品。它就像，它绝对还没有达到那个程度，但它只是非常有趣
it, an image of some kind, and you say, show me this in these different like styles, right? Or show me this in Star Wars, you know, or Transformers or Ghostbusters, or like, whatever, whatever the paradigm may be, but it's like, because it knows all of those things, it knows all the pop culture references, it can do this sort of interesting you know there's there's a real bunny hole there but like uh you can modulate a bunch of settings and then get a certain amount of like your input versus the the ai you know kind of a trace over of your given like image or or thought and then have it like spit back out some like well this is what it could look like you know well and for like vfx i could see it being a good polisher that when you
对我来说，所有这些技术以某种方式结合在一起，它们都是基于相同的电路，你知道，用于片场内视觉特效的实时图形是基于GPU的，对吧？然后所有的AI东西也是如此。因此，这些能够进行所有这些快速计算的非常具体的高功率电路，正是驱动我们如何快速大规模地为娱乐创造东西的时刻的动力。
get the broad strokes of the effect that you're going for it goes in and it cleans up the light rays or it cleans up the molten property of the water or the magic spell reflecting you know light around it doesn't require you know a team of 100 engineers to go through and visually change each thing but you still would need the human element of having the vision which i think ai can't do yeah absolutely distinguish between its own noise you know yeah and and i definitely where it is now it's not something that i would ever consider is like using for a totally finished product with no human intervention it's like it's not it's definitely not there yet but it's it's just very interesting
而且这在电影和演唱会制作中都是如此，你知道，有时它是电影的缩影，因为你正在为摄像机拍摄这种现场体验，但过去20年里发生的每一场演出都在艺人后面有一面巨大的LED墙。无论如何，你也在某种程度上拍摄它，这在某种程度上成为了你的背景，而且有更多实时工作投入到整合这一点上，这是五年前甚至不存在的。我认为这有点像如果你看汽车功能，那些相当主流并渗透到消费者空间的功能，
to me the way that all of these technologies have kind of like come together it's all sort of based on the same circuitry you know the the real-time graphics for in-camera vfx that is gpu based right and then so is all of the AI stuff. And so these very specific high-powered circuits that can do all this fast compute are the things that are driving kind of the moment of how we approach creating things rapidly at scale for entertainment.
很多东西，特别是关于燃油效率或安全性的东西，是在一级方程式赛车中作为最先进的技术发明的。然后它逐渐渗透下来。最终它变得更便宜了。但当你看看，你知道，演唱会技术，
And that's true across like film and across the concert production, which, you know, sometimes it's sort of a microcosm of film, because you're shooting this like live experience for camera, but every show that's happened in the last 20 years has had a big LED wall behind the talent. Anyways, you're also kind of filming that and that becomes your backdrop, in some ways, and there's been a lot more like real time work that's gone into integrating that that wasn't there even five years ago. I think it's kind of like how if you look at automotive features that are pretty mainstream that trickle into the consumer space,
声音和视觉技术，以及电影制作技术，其中很多都追随视频游戏，就像历史上一样，视频游戏在某种程度上开创了一件事。而且，你知道，你谈论的，
a lot of that stuff, especially like around fuel efficiency or safety is like invented in formula one as like just state ofof-the-art technology. And then it trickles down. Eventually it gets cheaper. But when you look at, you know, the concert technology,
也就是一个摄影棚，你不仅仅是在录制音轨和调整电平。你是在说，这里有声音的空间对象，你要移动它们，或者这里有视频视觉效果的空间对象，你知道，如果绝地武士走到这里，那么摄像机就知道移动背景，你知道，
sound and visual technology, and also filmmaking technology, so much of it follows video games, like over history, that video games kind of pioneer a thing. And that, you know, what you're talking about,
在他们身后的视频墙上。或者如果泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）走到这里，它知道它会放大这个来创造，你知道，增强这种景深之类的东西，但这些是相同的技术，它们本质上来自视频游戏引擎，你知道，像杜比全景声（Dolby Atmos），我不知道还有什么竞争技术，但这些空间，嗯，东西，而不是仅仅有一个声音，高端发烧友现在在他们的家庭影院系统中放入的东西，它不仅仅是，它是一个东西的非常好的录音，它知道你的扬声器在房间里的位置，它知道你
which is like a soundstage where you're not just recording a track and adjusting levels. You're saying here are spatial objects of sound that you're going to move around or here are spatial objects of a video visual effect that, you know, if it's the Jedi Knight walks over here, then the camera knows to move the background, you know,
在房间里的位置，并且当你观看蓝光光碟时，它会移动对象，比如一只鸟飞过头顶，但它是动态发生的，而且这些都是视频游戏的东西，你有声音点和键和目标对象等等。是的，杜比音频是一个很好的例子，因为那是一个相当新的东西，已经推出了，我想你知道，你现在进入的大多数剧院，如果他们在过去五年左右翻新了他们的东西，就会有它。但是的，他们确实有一张剧院本身扬声器阵列的图纸。然后有人做一个轨道，在那个网格周围移动音频。然后离它最近的任何扬声器都是声音最大的。
on the video wall behind them. Or if Taylor Swift moves over here, it knows that it's going to magnify this to create you know enhance this depth of field or something but those are the same technology and those essentially came from video game engines you know like the dolby atmos and there's i don't know what the other competing technology is but these spatial um things like instead of just having a sound the thing that the high-end audiophiles are putting in their home theater systems right now it's not just like it's a really good recording of a thing it knows where your speakers are in the room it knows where you
然后它会衰减。关于它的底层技术，我知之甚少，只能说它令人难以置信，而且它是你所做事情的声音版本，你让它把东西看作一个动态场，然后围绕观众看到的地方和角色要去的地方或动作发生的地方的参考点跟踪它们。嗯，但这很疯狂，你知道，因为当你想到，我想是文化，你知道，贯穿时间，就像人们过去常去，他们会去参观一个巨大的大教堂，他们会去参观世界上最好的油画，因为那是人类体验的巅峰，而现在你想到这一点，它在某种程度上，我想是电影和演唱会，你知道，你听过泰勒·斯威夫特的歌一百遍了，但工程师的目标是给你这个，团队给你这个，设计师给你这个体验，这不仅仅是音轨，你知道，这不仅仅是在足球场尽头看到泰勒作为一个小点，你正在通过这种人们像你创造的视听仪式与她交流。嗯，它归结为所有这些东西的一种驱动术语，对吧？这就是每个人都想为他们创造的任何体验使用的流行语，即沉浸感，对吧？它是沉浸式的吗？你感到沉浸在其中，被它包围了吗？
are in the room and it's moving the object around as you watch the blu-ray to say a bird flies overhead but it's happening dynamically and that those are that's all video game stuff that you you have sound points and keys and and target objects and all that stuff yeah the the dolby audio is a is a great example because that's a fairly new thing that's been rolled out i think a lot of you know most theaters that you go into now will have it if they have revamped their stuff in the last five years or so but yeah that they literally have a drawing of the array of speakers in the theater itself. And then there's someone that does a track that moves the audio around that, essentially that grid. And then whatever speakers are closest to it are the ones that are going to have it loudest.
你觉得你正在居住在这种所有这些人都在努力创造的体验中吗？嗯，一切都是为了那个主要的，你知道，那个原动力，即“我们是否沉浸在我们正在做的事情中？”以及什么感官知觉有助于那种沉浸感，对吧？所以这就是我们作为设计师试图做出的决定，并利用我们的直觉，即“这是否会服务于我们试图创造的沉浸式体验？”或者在某些情况下，打破人们的沉浸感，对吧？就像你在历史上有人试图翻转那种范式，我想到了布莱希特（Brecht）作为一个人，他想总是提醒人们你正在看戏，而不是沉浸其中，他想做这些打破你的大动作。但非常多的是，
And then it falls off. And I know very little about the underpinning technology of that other than to say that it's like incredible and what's the same it's the sound version of what you're doing though where you're having it kind of think of things as a dynamic field and then track them around reference points of what the audience sees and where the where the characters are going or whether right where the action is happening um but it is it is wild you know because i when you think of i guess culture you know throughout time like it's like people used to go and they would take like a trip to a giant cathedral they would take a trip to like go see like the best oil paintings in the world that
现在的模式是，我们希望人们尽可能地沉浸在体验中，无论是演唱会、电视节目、电影，还是，你知道，走过主题公园，
were on display because that was like the height of human experience of like and now you think about that and it's it's kind of i guess movies and concerts you know you've heard the taylor swift song a hundred times but it's the the goal of the engineer to give you this and and the crew to give you this and the designers to give you this experience that is more than the track you know it's not just getting to see taylor as a tiny dot at the end of the football stadium you're communing with her through this audio visual ritual that people like you create well and it and it comes down to kind of one sort of like driving term for all of this stuff right and it's the buzzword that everyone wants to use for whatever experience they're creating which is immersion right it's is it immersive do you feel immersed in it surrounded
对吧？我们不想只是走过世界，坐上游乐设施，看到熟悉的角色，我们想感觉我们是连续宇宙的一部分。所以即使在像，我认为“银河边缘”就是一个很好的例子，它想把人们置于主题公园的故事中，让你在在那里时成为叙事板的一部分。嗯，我也见过，我以前去过演唱会，那里有一些技术
by it do you feel like you're inhabiting this experience that all of these people are working to create um and everything is like in service of that primary you know that prime mover is like are we immersed in what we're doing and what sensory perception uh helps that immersion right so that's the decisions that we're trying to make and use our intuition on as designers is like will this serve the immersive experience that we're trying to create or in some cases break people's immersion right like you have people throughout history that have sought to like in like flip that paradigm like i think about brecht as someone who wants to like always remind people that you're watching a play rather than a mercy and that he wants to like do these big gestures that break you out of it. But very much the,
壮举令人难以置信，可能很昂贵，但它对连接我和艺术没有任何作用，它几乎就像是对重点的干扰，而我去过其他地方，我觉得我以这种方式体验了音乐，我再也无法以任何其他方式体验它，因为设计的体验，你知道，沉浸感，没有更好的词了。而且现在，你知道，艺术家因为Spotify之类的事情赚不到钱，所以有一种推动力让演唱会，你知道，艺术家必须销售，进行这些巨大的巡演。所以你看到了这个巨大的演唱会行业，它与20年前不同了。它不是去戴夫·马修斯（Dave Matthews）的演唱会，你知道，在草地上转动你的粗花呢裙子，然后，你知道，去那里。那里，那里，几乎就像现在一切都必须是烈焰红唇（Flaming Lips）的演唱会，你知道，呃，很多来自EDM世界的体验式东西现在都在微小的创作歌手演唱会中，你知道，一旦他们大到足以进行巡演。你能说点关于
the mode right now is like, we want people as in the experience as possible, whether it's a concert, a TV show, a movie, or, you know, walking through a theme park,
当技术工作时，你知道，设计师如何与艺术家合作来规划体验，然后当它失败时，当它工作时，你知道，是什么让它成为一个系统？是的，我认为，嗯，所以很多时候，呃，特别是在我现在所处的领域，对吧？我们有，呃，会有像创意总监，与艺术家密切合作，或者，有时那是我们，但有时有，你知道，作为团队一部分的外部方，作为创造体验使命的一部分，但它总是想从艺术家想要什么开始，就像他们为巡演梦想什么一样。所以他们告诉你这是专辑的重点，或者这是我在说的话，以一种他们可能不在专辑中明确说出的方式。是的，或者他们会
right? Like we don't want to just go walk through the, the, the world and ride the ride and see the familiar like characters we want to feel like we're a part of the contiguous universe and so even in like how like i think galaxy's edge is a is a great example of that where it's like it wants to put people in the story of the theme park and like have you be a part of the narrative board while you're there well i think uh too like the i've seen i've been to concerts before where there was some technical
对吧？我们不想只是走马观花地游览世界，坐坐游乐设施，看看熟悉的那些角色，我们想感觉自己是这个连续宇宙的一部分。所以我认为“银河边缘”就是一个很好的例子，它试图把人们置于主题公园的故事中，让你在游玩时成为叙事的一部分。嗯，我也觉得……我以前看过一些演唱会，那里有一些技术上的壮举，虽然令人印象深刻，可能也花了大价钱，但它们并没有让我与艺术产生任何联系，甚至起到了反作用，分散了人们对核心内容的注意力。而我曾去过其他地方，在那里我感觉自己以一种前所未有的方式体验了音乐，这种体验是独一无二的，因为那是精心设计的，用一个词来说就是“沉浸感”。现在，由于Spotify等平台的存在，艺人们赚不到什么钱，所以他们不得不进行大规模巡演。因此，你看到的这个庞大的演唱会产业与20年前完全不同了。不再是去听戴夫·马修斯的演唱会，在草地上转着你的粗花呢裙子，然后……现在几乎每场演唱会都得像“烈焰红唇”乐队的演出一样。很多来自电子舞曲（EDM）领域的体验式元素，现在甚至出现在小型唱作人的演唱会中，只要他们有足够的规模去巡演。你能谈谈……
feat that was incredibly impressive and probably expensive but it didn't do anything to connect me to the art it didn't do anything it almost like was a distraction from what was the point whereas i've been to other places where i felt like i experienced the music in this way um that i could never could again and never could have any other way because of the experience that was designed and you know the immersion for lack of a better word um and now that you know artists don't make any money because of spotify and things, there's been this push to make concerts, you know, artists have to sell, do these huge tours. And so you see this huge concert industry that is different than it was 20 years ago. It's not going to the Dave Matthews concert and, you know, twirling your tweed skirt on the grass and then, you know, going like there right there there's this it's almost like everything has to be a flaming lips concert now you know uh a lot of that uh experiential stuff from like edm the edm world is now like in tiny singer songwriter concerts you know as soon as they're big enough to have a tour can you say something about like
当技术运作良好时，设计师是如何与艺人合作来规划体验的？而当技术失效或成功时，是什么让它成为一个系统？
when the technology is working you know how does the designer like work with the artist to plan an experience and then when when that fails when that works you know what what what makes that what makes that a system yeah i think um so a lot of times uh especially in in the world that i'm in right now right like we have um uh there will be like a creative director uh that's working very closely with uh the artist or um sometimes that's us but sometimes there's you know an outside party who's part of the team part of the uh the mission of like making the experience but it always kind of wants to start with what the artist wants like what they're dreaming of for their tour so they tell you this is the point of the album or this is what i'm saying in a way that maybe they don't say explicitly on the album yeah um or the they'll
是的，我认为……很多时候，特别是在我目前所处的领域，我们会有创意总监与艺人紧密合作。有时是我们自己，有时是团队外部的成员，他们的使命就是打造这种体验。但这一切总是始于艺人的需求，始于他们对巡演的构想。他们会告诉你这张专辑的核心意义是什么，或者他们以一种在专辑中没有明确表达的方式来传达某种信息，或者他们会……
give us whatever kind of like inspiration resources assets that they've already been like percolating on because oftentimes you know there is an album that's like the reason for the tour or there is a you know a driving force behind you know sometimes it's like oh this band has been around for 30 years we're going to do a 30th like anniversary tour so then it's like well we want this to be a retrospective or conversely we want to be looking forward you know instead of looking back and so there's a lot of times like that's where it all starts is with what the what is the experience that the artist is trying to create. And then we're looking at, OK, how do we execute that? What can we add to that vision?
提供任何他们已经在构思的灵感资源或素材，因为通常来说，巡演背后总有一张专辑作为核心驱动力，或者某种推动力。有时是因为乐队成立30周年，我们要举办30周年巡演，那么我们就会考虑是做一场回顾展，还是反过来，展望未来而不是回顾过去。所以很多时候，一切都始于艺术家想要创造什么样的体验。然后我们再考虑，OK，我们该如何实现它？我们能为这个愿景增添什么？
And then, you know, on the backside side of it is like what are the practical components that you need to achieve that um and it can be wildly different for um depending on the show and the day uh but it's a lot of times like this iterative iterative process where it's like we we get the initial uh brief right and then we go into the minds and we extract uh some ideas from the like raw materials that we have available to us and then we come back and we say okay this is our approach to the vision do you feel like this is working do you feel like this serves um the uh the overall idea that you're trying to connect to your audience through. And that process can take several passes.
接下来，在后端，我们需要考虑实现这一目标所需的实际组件。根据演出和日期的不同，这些组件可能会有巨大的差异。但这通常是一个迭代的过程，我们先拿到初步的简报，然后深入挖掘，从现有的原始素材中提取一些想法，再回来沟通说，这是我们对这个愿景的处理方式，你觉得这样可行吗？你觉得这是否符合你想要传达给观众的整体理念？这个过程可能需要反复多次。
We get feedback, we go back, we come back. And throughout that whole thing... What do you do when you have somebody that's just impossible? They want you to do... They think they can do your job better than you or they don't understand the... So as an individual i feel like individual designers me personally i feel like it's my goal not to let anything that i've done get precious right if
我们获取反馈，回去修改，再回来。在整个过程中……如果遇到那种不可理喻的人该怎么办？他们想让你做……他们认为自己比你更懂你的工作，或者他们根本不理解……作为一名设计师，我个人的目标是，绝不让自己所做的任何东西变得“珍贵”到不可触碰。
there's um my goal is to serve the show and and the the artist that's trying to put the show on so if something i'm doing is like not resonating with them, it's not in service of their vision, then like I'm okay letting a lot of things go. If I'm really like excited about the idea, maybe I'll put it in my back pocket for later. But I think that it's more important to do the show that they want to do and let them drive it.
我的目标是服务于演出和想要呈现这场演出的艺术家。如果我做的事情无法引起他们的共鸣，或者不符合他们的愿景，那么我愿意放弃很多东西。如果我真的很喜欢某个想法，也许我会把它先存起来留待以后使用。但我认为，完成他们想要的演出并让他们主导，这更为重要。
And the only time I think that we try to like push back is if there's a true like practical like we cannot get the trust we cannot get the like lights we cannot get the physical product that we need to make this happen for reason of availability or budget or whatever um those are the moments where it's like you know we might have to have a dialogue about it um but broadly speaking i think you know i would rather champion my ideas but not defend them to the death yeah um well and it does seem like you know the designer or something used to just kind of be you know more independent artists but the kind of work that you're doing almost seems like it's more kind of religious or shamanic and
我认为我们唯一会反驳的情况是，存在真正的实际困难，比如因为可用性或预算等原因，我们无法获得所需的设备、灯光或实物产品。在这些时刻，我们可能需要进行对话。但总的来说，我宁愿捍卫我的想法，而不是死守不放。确实，过去设计师似乎更像是独立的艺术家，但你所从事的工作似乎更具有某种宗教或萨满色彩。
that you're trying to connect people to this greater experience you know and just the nuts and bolts of how you you know get the sound to 80 people or whatever i mean it's definitely the nuts and bolts too but i think it's important to sort of hold both of those things in concert with each other, right? Like to be the conduit through which the nuts and bolts become the broader experience. And the great thing about it being this hugely, massively collaborative effort between a lot of creative people and a lot of like technical, you know, engineering types. And being a collaborative art form as live entertainment and film theater all are, is that there's space for everyone
你试图将人们与这种更宏大的体验连接起来。当然，如何将声音传达给80个人之类的基础工作也必不可少，但我认为将这两者结合起来非常重要，对吧？成为将基础技术转化为更广泛体验的渠道。而作为现场娱乐、电影和戏剧，这是一项由众多创意人员和技术工程人员共同参与的巨大协作工程，其伟大之处在于，每个人都有空间。
to like inhabit both of those roles. You know, like I always like to think that like a good creative idea can come from anywhere in the production team. It doesn't have to come from you know me the designer it can come from the audio engineer or the the screens programmer or anybody in that process and i think that the more that we kind of all work together toward that vision the better product you're going to end up having because everyone believes in it you have to believe in the world
去扮演这两种角色。我总是认为，好的创意可以来自制作团队的任何地方。它不一定非要来自我这个设计师，它可以来自音响工程师、屏幕程序员或过程中的任何人。我认为我们越是朝着同一个愿景共同努力，最终的产品就会越好，因为每个人都相信它。你必须相信你为观众创造的世界。
that you're creating for the audience because otherwise they're never going to believe it. Yeah. Yeah. And I think that was the complaint about from the filmmakers and actors and also the audiences of that kind of low point and technology being misapplied as people said that they didn't believe it. You know, there's that I was kind of surprised that they even put it on there. there was like that clip on the behind the scenes of the hobbit you know blu-ray or something where um there he you know ian mckellen's saying that he just broke down crying and was like this is not why oh yeah because he was trying to talk to 18 dwarfs on sticks and he just couldn't get into the pictures and it's like him and a bunch of green boxes on a green set, but he's in full gay makeup, and it's such a jarring juxtaposition. And it's like, if your job as an actor is to believe in the world and inhabit it fully, and you're surrounded by nothing that even resembles what it is
否则他们永远不会相信。是的。我认为这也是电影制作人、演员以及观众对那个技术被误用的低谷期的抱怨，人们说他们无法相信那个世界。我当时很惊讶他们竟然把那个片段放进去了，就是《霍比特人》幕后花絮里的那个片段，伊恩·麦克莱恩说他崩溃大哭，说这不是他想要的……因为他当时试图对着棍子上的18个矮人说话，他完全无法进入状态。他周围只有一堆绿色的盒子和绿色的布景，但他却化着全套的妆容，这种并置太刺眼了。如果作为演员，你的工作是相信这个世界并完全沉浸其中，而你周围没有任何东西像你试图描绘的那样。
you're trying to portray, then how could you get into character? How could you how could you get into character like how could you you know well and it's not like the process of filmmaking um or you know the process of like doing a concert the nuts and bolts of that haven't ever been at odds with the art i mean just you go to basic cinematography like if you shoot a conversation wide the actors can just talk and it's natural if you're trying to shot reverse shot in a very tight way, you're having to make them say every single line at the camera and then stop and then set up for 15 minutes or an hour and then come back and say the next line of a conversation and then their ability to keep that in flow of conversation. And that's old school, you know, filmmaking. So it's not,
那你怎么能进入角色呢？怎么能进入角色呢？嗯，这并不是说电影制作的过程，或者举办演唱会的过程，其基础技术与艺术之间一直存在冲突。比如基本的电影摄影，如果你拍摄一场对话的广角镜头，演员们可以自然地交谈。但如果你试图以非常紧凑的方式拍摄正反打镜头，你必须让他们对着摄像机说出每一句台词，然后停下来，花15分钟或一个小时重新布景，然后再回来接着说对话的下一句，这会影响他们保持对话流畅的能力。那是老派的电影制作方式。所以，
these aren't terribly new problems, but I think, you know, just like anything technology is kind of a n non-specific amplifier. It makes, you know. Yeah, that's a super good point that like the nature of the actor's work is definitely to be able to like embody those states in any circumstance. But I think that, yeah, the technology, in the same way that it's like a force amplifier for creative work right a productivity amplifier it can also amplify all of those like jarring things um for the actor and i think too that it comes down to like experience like ian mckellar in particular i think about like his long and
这些并不是什么全新的问题，但我认为，就像任何事物一样，技术是一种非特定的放大器。它会让……是的，这是一个非常好的观点，演员的工作本质上确实是在任何情况下都能体现这些状态。但我认为，技术就像是创意工作的力量放大器，也是生产力的放大器，它同样会放大所有那些对演员来说刺眼的东西。而且我认为这也归结于经验，特别是像伊恩·麦克莱恩，我想到他漫长而。
storied history of being a conventional theatrical actor so so that experience of just living on the in a play where you're doing the dialogue for two hours sometimes yeah and yeah in real time in that wide shot scenario right so there is no stop down there is no uh resetting the shot it's like you get one run at it and that's what the audience is going to remember so you i could see especially for someone like that being in that circumstance uh with the green screen would just be extremely jarring because of his own experiences. Whereas someone that's like newer to the game, just coming up in it, it's like,
传奇的传统戏剧演员生涯。那种在戏剧中连续表演两个小时对话的经历，是的，在实时广角镜头的情况下，没有停顿，没有重新拍摄，你只有一次机会，而那正是观众会记住的。所以我可以理解，对于像他这样的人来说，在那种绿幕环境下，由于他自己的经验，会感到极其不协调。而对于刚入行的新人来说，
Oh yeah, this is just part of the game. Somebody who's an ADD TikTok streamer that was, you know, like they, they're going to be able to adapt to that world better. I wonder if it is like the, the jump from,
哦，是的，这就是游戏的一部分。一个习惯了TikTok的ADD主播，他们能够更好地适应那个世界。我不知道这是否就像……
you know, famously like a lot of actors could not jump into talkies when when sound was added to movies they couldn't make the cut because they're they couldn't project or their voice didn't fit the character type that they could play in silent film or something like that um you know maybe not as dramatic but i wonder if there's not something here that you have the the way that film is made and presented changing so quickly that certain um legacy types of acting style can't keep up or maybe this changes acting style that people who came up and all they know is the led wall are gonna have you know be a noticeably different movement of acting you know when you look back on it 50 years from now right yeah i think yeah it's
你知道，众所周知，很多演员在电影中加入声音时无法适应有声电影，他们无法胜任，因为他们无法发声，或者他们的声音不适合他们在默片中扮演的角色类型。也许没有那么戏剧性，但我怀疑，电影制作和呈现方式的变化如此之快，以至于某些传统的表演风格无法跟上，或者这改变了表演风格，那些只知道LED墙的人，50年后回顾时，会发现他们的表演动作有明显的不同，对吧？是的，我想是的。
i think that's one thing that like a lot of times i'll say like the future of what we do is impossible to predict but i think that the cycles are predictable and i think we didn't see the the move from silent film to talkies uh created a um like a struggle of evolution and then from uh but also from like uh theatrical uh actors to film actors but then also the other direction like whenever there's like a resurgence in broadway interest and someone from movies uh tries to go be a broadway performer and uh if they don't have the right like sound amplification like those people have a lot of like difficulty projecting for a crowd uh in a in a space because they're used to projecting for a boom mic directly over
我认为有一点是肯定的，我常说我们所做之事的未来是无法预测的，但我认为周期是可以预测的。我们看到了从默片到有声电影的转变，创造了一种进化的挣扎，然后从戏剧演员到电影演员的转变，但反过来也是如此。每当百老汇出现复兴，电影演员试图去当百老汇演员时，如果他们没有合适的扩音设备，那些人很难在空间里为观众投射声音，因为他们习惯了对着头顶上方的吊杆麦克风发声。
their head um and i wonder uh if i wonder like how bad it would be to put Eddie Redmayne in a play, because even with the wonders of, you know, THX advanced audio, every movie that I've ever seen Eddie Redmayne in is him going. Right. Yeah. It's someone who's very quiet. Like they're going to have trouble in a theatrical space,
我不知道让埃迪·雷德梅恩去演戏会有多糟糕，因为即使有THX高级音频的奇迹，我看过的每一部埃迪·雷德梅恩的电影，他都是这样。对，是的。他是一个非常安静的人。他们在戏剧空间里会有麻烦，
even with the mics and the amplification that we have, because it's just it's a different paradigm um and it all comes back to like what people are used to i'm curious too because like a lot of this stuff is cheaper to make than it's ever been because of technology like you're describing at disney or you know just some of these concerts would not have been possible i mean you just could not have concerts on that scale, you know, even 10 years ago, some of them, what they're able to do now. But I wonder if that changes the way that content is kind of produced and who has access to it and who you distribute versus who you don't, you know, like, it seems like like things like electronic music tend to stay in the festival circuit, like you have to go camp out and you know maybe you know take mushrooms or something if you're going to go listen to a certain kind of band whereas you know the live nations are not doing those as much as it's a different investor pool it's a different business
即使有我们现在的麦克风和扩音设备，因为这是完全不同的范式。这一切都归结于人们习惯了什么。我也很好奇，因为由于技术原因，很多东西的制作成本比以往任何时候都要低。就像你描述的迪士尼，或者一些演唱会，在10年前甚至都不可能实现，他们现在能做到的事情。但我不知道这是否改变了内容的生产方式，谁拥有访问权，谁分发，谁不分发。比如，电子音乐往往停留在音乐节巡演中，你必须去露营，也许还要吃点蘑菇之类的才能去听某种乐队，而Live Nation并没有像那样做，这是一个不同的投资者群体，是一个不同的商业模式。
model than the taylor swift concert you know or the drake tour yeah i think excuse me i think that there has definitely been a democratization of the tools for creativity um the fact that you can you know there are free and open source alternatives for just about any like creative platform that's out there so if you're willing to like take the time to learn those and become dexterous in them in the same way that the like mainstream tools are um you can create like there's there's very little uh barrier between what someone can create working you know in their house on a gaming laptop and what someone can create in a multi-million dollar studio other than time and like number of people that are like all throwing their work at it at once and i think that um i think that's a very exciting thing because it allows for so many more people to do interesting things and take bigger risks than like the the large budgeted studios are willing to make
比起泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会或德雷克的巡演。是的，我认为，抱歉，我认为创意工具确实实现了民主化。事实上，几乎所有现有的创意平台都有免费和开源的替代品。所以如果你愿意花时间去学习并变得熟练，就像使用主流工具一样，你可以在家里用游戏笔记本电脑创造出与数百万美元工作室相媲美的作品，除了时间和投入的人力之外，几乎没有障碍。我认为这是一件非常令人兴奋的事情，因为它让更多的人能够做有趣的事情，并承担比大预算工作室愿意承担的更大的风险。
you know you can you know if you have an idea for something and access to youtube like you can teach yourself how to do it um with more ease um than i think there ever has been and increasingly some of those open source tools are like working their way into the mainstream anyway because as more people like put their efforts behind developing those programs uh their viability just kind of comes on the same level as the the professional tool sets um so then it comes back to like what are you used to using or what can you teach yourself how to adapt to um so i think it's a super exciting time in that way for those more like indie projects um and i guess i'm thinking more in like animation and like short form like video that's where you see a lot of those like
如果你对某事有想法并且能接触到YouTube，你可以比以往任何时候都更容易地自学如何去做。而且越来越多的开源工具正在进入主流，因为随着越来越多的人投入精力开发这些程序，它们的实用性已经达到了与专业工具集相同的水平。所以这又回到了你习惯使用什么，或者你能自学适应什么。所以我认为对于那些更像独立项目的作品来说，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时代。我想我更多是在动画和短视频领域，那是你看到很多独立创意成形的地方。
indie ideas like take shape but the production value on some of the stuff that's like out there is astounding for it being like you guys just how was it uh that uh godzilla minus one or godzilla that recent. I remember looking at the effects of that versus the giant U S big budget, you know, 480 million plus marketing deal. And it was just like, this one looks better,
但其中一些作品的制作价值令人震惊，你们是怎么做到的？比如《哥斯拉-1.0》或者最近的那部哥斯拉。我记得对比过它的特效和美国那些4.8亿美元加营销预算的大片。结果就是，这部看起来更好，
you know, and they spent a million dollars. How did they do that? Yeah. And I love that one because of the stylistic, like sort of throwbacks to the, the early Godzilla movies too. Just like,
而且他们只花了一百万美元。他们是怎么做到的？是的，我喜欢那一部，因为它在风格上有一种对早期哥斯拉电影的致敬。就像，
it seems like filmically it feels, and it's one of the things that like, I can't articulate it even though I'm watching it, but like, it feels like an old school Godzilla movie. Um, but done in like a very sort of modern quality production, uh,
在电影感上，虽然我无法准确表达，但我看的时候感觉它就像一部老派的哥斯拉电影。但是以一种非常现代的高质量制作方式完成的。
value kind of way. Um, and it's, and I think that's you know i'm excited for more things like that to happen as as this technology continues to i hope uh spread and become uh more available to more people that are interested in like getting into this world yeah it's fascinating the and do you have any idea where it goes from here do you see you know the the next version of this being that you could you know unroll the the dot light tarp in your apartment and have you know somehow the ability to do what we're now doing in studios you know uh for a couple hundred bucks on on the gaming laptop or you know where where does this go uh i'm gonna go back to
我为未来能有更多这样的事情发生感到兴奋，随着这项技术继续传播并变得对更多感兴趣的人可用。是的，这太迷人了。你对未来有什么想法吗？你认为下一个版本会是你可以把点阵灯光布在公寓里，然后以几百美元的价格在游戏笔记本电脑上实现我们现在在工作室里做的事情吗？或者这会走向何方？我会回到。
my it's impossible to predict uh answer first and then i'll qualify that um because i do think that as the technology continues to advance and expand uh i think i think all it will take is for one person to like find the right combination of pieces and parts and do that and then show everyone how it was done. And then I think you'll see an explosion of everybody trying to do it. Because that's what happened with in-camera VFX is that virtual production became a buzzword as soon as one show did really well using that production paradigm um and then all of a sudden everyone's trying to do it right and there's this huge like glut of shows that are all using led volumes as their backdrop um and and some do it really well uh and some don't do it as well and And, um, and that's kind of the nature of like seeing what works and what doesn't.
我那句“无法预测”的回答，然后我会补充说明。因为我确实认为，随着技术的不断进步和扩展，我认为只需要一个人找到零件的正确组合并做到这一点，然后向大家展示它是如何完成的。然后你会看到每个人都试图去做的爆发。因为这就是虚拟制作（In-camera VFX）发生的情况，一旦一个节目使用这种制作范式取得了成功，虚拟制作就成了流行语，然后突然间每个人都在尝试这样做，市场上充斥着使用LED墙作为背景的节目。有些做得很好，有些则不然。
But, uh, I, I would hope to see more of the, the like indie projects using that kind of tech in the future because of the wide availability. And it may not be like roll out the dot matrix in your apartment but it may be you can rent this super high resolution led tile from the like local you know rental house and you know uh book a studio space for a week and go in and shoot your whole thing in that like one week of filming and then that becomes like the breakout way of doing you you know, the next cool thing. Do any of this go into like live action plays like Broadway type stuff? It seems like sometimes they resist technology and plays more than even in like, you know, music. music? I've seen a couple of and I can't think of specifics right now. But I have seen a couple
这就是观察什么有效、什么无效的本质。但我希望看到更多独立项目在未来使用这种技术，因为它的广泛可用性。它可能不是在你的公寓里铺开点阵屏，但可能是你可以从当地租赁公司租用这种超高分辨率的LED砖，预订一周的工作室空间，进去拍摄你的整个作品，然后那就会成为那种突破性的方式。这些技术会进入百老汇式的现场戏剧吗？似乎有时他们比音乐界更抵制技术。
shows that use LED backdrop as opposed to like a painted or practical set. I've seen more projection use in in theatrical production. But again, that technology has been around longer and you can kind of get away with some like stylistic choices in projection that you can't necessarily with like the led um something about the way the led contributes to the light of a given environment makes it so that if it's not almost a character in the show itself, um, and I think can make it kind of hard to, uh, juxtapose with the action, uh,
我见过一些使用LED背景而不是手绘或实景布景的演出。我在戏剧制作中见过更多的投影使用。但同样，这项技术存在的时间更长，你可以在投影中运用一些风格化的选择，而LED则不一定。LED对环境光线的贡献方式使得它如果不是演出本身的一个角色，就很难与表演并置。
in a, in a theatrical environment and the projection being just a little bit softer. Um, but with led, you don't have to fight your lighting. Doesn't have to fight your back wall. Whereas with projection,
在戏剧环境中，投影稍微柔和一些。但有了LED，你就不必担心你的灯光会与背景墙冲突。而使用投影时，
you always have to be super careful about whether or not you're accidentally washing yeah that content um so there's pros and cons to either one i think we will i think we'll probably see more led i think something that it could be very useful for is like uh what what we call like set extension um where it's like you've built. You project the set around the audience or something? Well, more so like you've built your practical set on stage, right, in your traditional proscenium set. But then behind that, your last piece is an LED wall that's able to change. If it's like you've got the buildings of a fishing village or
你总是必须非常小心，以免意外地冲淡了内容。所以两者各有利弊。我认为我们可能会看到更多的LED。我认为它非常有用的地方是所谓的“布景延伸”，比如你已经搭建好了。你把布景投射到观众周围？更像是你在舞台上搭建了实景布景，在传统的镜框式舞台上。但在那之后，最后一部分是一面可以改变的LED墙。如果你有渔村的建筑，
something right and that's and that's where your play takes place and then it's like you draw the rest of the fishing village and the like ocean and the sunset and the backdrop and then because it's a real-time video piece it's like now you've got the whole village kind of realized and you can do progression through time of day or change the lighting or bring in a thunderstorm or like all of these things that you can do as long as you've got like a content guy that's able to like create those effects um and then you get the real lighting of that on your your practical physical village um it's and i'm drawing from a couple of things i have seen recently. So the artist, The Weeknd, one of his more recent stadium set designs was this big cityscape, practical set,
那就是你的戏发生的地方，然后你画出渔村的其余部分、海洋、日落和背景。因为这是一个实时视频片段，现在你有了整个村庄的呈现，你可以进行一天中时间的推移，改变灯光，或者引入雷暴，只要你有一个能够创造这些效果的内容制作人。然后你的实景村庄就会获得真实的灯光效果。我借鉴了我最近看到的一些东西。比如威肯（The Weeknd），他最近的一场体育场巡演设计就是一个巨大的城市景观，实景布景，
illuminated windows on these buildings that were like platforms and things. And then behind that was the rest of the city. And they would just transform that cityscape using, you know, CG effects and things on the LED wall and then change the lighting and sort of like that would evoke the same stylistic choices on the practical elements. So it felt like this like city was moving through these fast changes. That's cool. Yeah. I mean, again, I'm thinking of the witcher one had this dynamic weather that didn't was, it wasn't really cued to anything in a script. It would just naturally blow across the world as you were exploring.
这些建筑上有发光的窗户，就像平台一样。在那后面是城市的其余部分。他们会使用LED墙上的CG效果来变换那个城市景观，然后改变灯光，从而在实景元素上唤起同样的风格选择。所以感觉就像这座城市在这些快速变化中移动。那很酷。是的，我再次想到《巫师》游戏，它有动态天气，并不是剧本中设定的。当你探索时，它会自然地吹过世界。
And this was this like amazing thing that you would never experience the same combination of like light, light direction, weather, wind, humidity, and all of it was controlled separately and sort of mixed together. And now that stuff is,
这是一种令人惊叹的事情，你永远不会体验到光线、光线方向、天气、风、湿度等相同组合的体验，所有这些都是单独控制并混合在一起的。现在这些东西正在流入电影中。
is trickling into, into film. Yeah, totally. And, and it's like, you got to find the right application for it. Um,
是的，完全正确。你必须找到正确的应用方式。
certainly cause it could become so distracting to the action of the story that it's like, now it's not serving that creative anymore, but as like a, as a subtle sort of inclusion, i think it has a lot of potential yeah then when the smart home thing was going on i remember like they were like well if you spent two hundred dollars more on light bulbs you can have like a lightning storm embrace your kitchen then i was like well okay that's kind of neat but i don't really i don't think i want that
当然，因为它可能会变得非常分散故事动作的注意力，以至于它不再服务于创意。但作为一种微妙的融入，我认为它有很多潜力。是的，当智能家居刚出现时，我记得他们说如果你多花200美元买灯泡，你就可以在厨房里拥有雷暴效果，当时我就想，好吧，那挺整洁的，但我真的不认为我想要那个。
i'm very broke and a social worker in alabama but you could see you know if you're doing like a role playing you know dnd or something that there a lot of that stuff being cheaper and easier for the individual to program from their phone makes absolutely exciting opportunities and they've actually there's a i just saw this this is not related at all to what I do or anything, but there's a product that's a set of like, you know, polyhedral dice that are connected to an app that has hooks into one of the like common home automation platforms. If this, then that it, and so it's like you can set conditions where it's like, Oh,
我是一个在阿拉巴马州的穷困社会工作者，但你可以看到，如果你在进行角色扮演游戏（D&D），那么这些东西变得更便宜、更容易让个人通过手机编程，确实创造了令人兴奋的机会。我刚刚看到这个，这与我所做的完全无关，但有一个产品是一套连接到应用程序的多面骰子，它与常见的家庭自动化平台挂钩。如果这样，就那样，所以你可以设置条件，比如，哦，
if I roll a natural 20 if that's and that is going to go hit all of the lights in my oh wow dragons room and like change the color like do a strobe or whatever you program and so it's like there is kind of like uh and and in that way right it serves that immersion because now it's like this thing has happened for this character and now the world changes as a result of it and it's like you feel that because the world around you has changed your perception has changed because you've got this tie into this technology that can you know change the environment of the lighting or make a sound effect in the room from like speakers or something like triggered on an action in real time, as opposed to being a pre-programmed sort of like a cute element.
如果我掷出了一个自然20，它就会触发我房间里所有的灯光，改变颜色，或者进行频闪，或者任何你编程的效果。所以这确实服务于沉浸感，因为现在这个角色发生了这件事，世界也随之改变了。你感受到了，因为你周围的世界改变了，你的感知也改变了，因为你与这种技术有了联系，可以改变灯光环境，或者从扬声器中发出音效，而不是预先编程的提示元素。
Yeah. And you, you, as you make the environment more automated or more able to just react to things organically and you're thinking about it less as part of your process, it just becomes something that enhances that, you know, I think James Cameron was kind of ahead of the curve when he was talking about avatar because he basically was doing this but with technology that wasn't here yet um i mean you granted you needed 200 million dollars to do that back then but that was sort of why avatar worked in a way that a lot of those things did not work um oh absolutely well well that's interesting stuff um do you what do you think about like um you know because the
是的。当你让环境更加自动化，或者更能有机地对事物做出反应，而你减少对过程的思考时，它就变成了增强体验的东西。我认为詹姆斯·卡梅隆在谈论《阿凡达》时走在了前面，因为他基本上是在做这件事，但使用的是当时还不存在的技术。当然，你当时需要2亿美元才能做到，但这正是《阿凡达》成功的原因，而很多其他作品没有成功。这很有趣。你觉得……
world that you're building for the artist already is sort of you know a digital space you know to you take to the concert do you see things like ar vr concerts where you buy a ticket and put on a hololens and you know walk around and see the live concert you know becoming something that are are the direction things go in or is that um it's so there have been some like executions of that um that i've seen uh that are like fun um it's something that i kind of daydream about uh a lot of the time is like you know the glasses are like almost there they're so close uh they're not there yet um but it is a time it's like, you know, the glasses are like almost there. They're so close. They're not there yet. But it is a very, it's like you can look at it through your phone.
你为艺术家构建的世界本身就是一个数字空间，你带到演唱会上。你认为AR/VR演唱会，比如你买票戴上Hololens，走来走去观看现场演唱会，会成为未来的方向吗？还是说……有一些我见过的执行案例，很有趣。这是我经常幻想的事情，眼镜几乎快要成功了，它们非常接近，但还没有完全达到。但这是一个……眼镜几乎快要成功了。它们非常接近。它们还没有达到。但这是一个，你可以通过手机看到它。
And so often people have their phones out anyway at a concert. So there's definitely potential there that like you scan a QR code and you get an app. And that app is basically running a separate, you know, composite plate across your phone that's like tracking spatially and can show you like this added layer of performance um and i think that like that has a ton of interesting potential um in maybe the next 10 years 10 15 um but i'm all i'm always like open to being surprised and be like oh someone already did it and i just didn't know about it like that happens to me all the time um i think that creating that sort of um i don't know it's like they talk about you know uh for a while there was like the third screen was kind of the,
所以人们在演唱会上无论如何都会拿出手机。所以这绝对有潜力，比如你扫描二维码，得到一个应用程序。该应用程序基本上在你的手机上运行一个单独的合成层，进行空间跟踪，并可以向你展示这种增加的表演层。我认为这在未来10到15年内有巨大的潜力。但我总是乐于被惊喜，比如“哦，有人已经做到了，我只是不知道”。这种情况经常发生在我身上。我认为创造那种……我不知道，他们谈论过，有一段时间，第三屏幕在视频游戏和一些电视节目中是一个概念性的东西。对吧。但你会有一个应用程序，在观看节目时在手机上查看。那东西杀死了它，
um, a conceptual thing in video games and, and some TV as well. Right. But you'd have like an app that would like call on the show. And that's what you'd look at on your phone while you're watching it. Uh, sort of killed that,
对吧。是的，死得非常突然，而且完全可以预见。我不知道。是的。
uh, right. Yeah. Died a very sudden death and, uh, and completely predictable one. I don't know. Yeah. Uh, and very sudden death and, and completely predictable one. I don't know. Yeah. And then everyone kind of backed away from it. But I think there is going to be at least
死得非常突然，而且完全可以预见。我不知道。是的。然后每个人都退缩了。但我认为至少会有。
continued like experimentation in like, how do we bring that? Because that is another component of the like in camera VFX paradigm is like you'll have the led wall set extension but then you may also have like a foreground uh that is the ar component where it's like you're generating things not only behind the performance but also in front of it or interacting through it those seem to be really involved right because now you've got to track where the the virtual object is in space relative to your performers who are real relative to the background. And so that can get very complicated, very fast and requires a lot of...
持续的实验，比如，我们如何引入它？因为这是虚拟制作范式中的另一个组成部分，比如你会有LED墙布景延伸，但你可能也会有作为AR组件的前景，即你不仅在表演后面生成东西，还在前面生成东西，或者与之互动。这些看起来非常复杂，因为现在你必须跟踪虚拟物体在空间中相对于作为真实表演者的位置，以及相对于背景的位置。所以这会变得非常复杂，非常快，并且需要大量的……
Well, they're tracking a lot of them with digital kind of chips and body tags anyway, where the light to hit and the laser effect to come on. I mean, they're already doing it. Or where the shotgun mic is going to point for some things. Yeah, yeah. We definitely have like, you know know performer trackers for spotlights and things like that and it's like if you can feed all of that data into one uh homogenized system which those those platforms do exist um but it comes down to like you have to have very tight calibration and you have to have like very strong process. Shake your Taylor Swift in a figure eight until the compass points North again. Yeah. You know,
好吧，无论如何，他们用数字芯片和身体标签跟踪其中的许多东西，以确定灯光照射的位置和激光效果出现的位置。我的意思是，他们已经在做了。或者霰弹麦克风指向哪里。是的，我们确实有用于聚光灯等的表演者跟踪器。如果能将所有这些数据输入到一个同质化的系统中，这些平台确实存在，但归结为必须有非常严格的校准和非常强大的流程。把泰勒·斯威夫特像8字形一样摇晃，直到指南针再次指向北方。是的。你知道，
there's, there's a little bit of that, right? It's like, you gotta like grab the tracker and you've got to like walk it around the stage and be sure. And it's like, if that data drops for any reason,
有一点那种感觉，对吧？你必须抓住跟踪器，绕着舞台走，确保一切正常。如果数据因为任何原因丢失，
then suddenly things will go a wire because you're getting position values that are like nulls. So it's like you can do those things they're not totally um or at least in my experience uh you have to have a more controlled environment they're not so like shoot from the hip yet that you can just like deploy it and it'll just work it's like there's a lot of fine tuning but it is one of those things that's like constantly improving and developing um again i think we'll see more of the easier it gets to like deploy those things well which maybe you know synthesizes things like movies and
那么事情就会乱套，因为你得到的定位值是空值。所以你可以做这些事情，它们不是完全……或者至少在我的经验中，你必须有一个更受控的环境。它们还不是那种“即插即用”的程度，你不能只是部署它，它就能工作。需要大量的微调，但这是那种不断改进和发展的事情。同样，我认为随着部署这些东西变得越来越容易，我们会看到更多。这也许能整合电影、
concerts and and plays as they're using the same technology, you know? I mean, I think that the 360 camera thing came and went too early. Like it kind of, they shot their shot. Everyone wanted to do an, you know, Silicon Valley has to pretend like one thing's going to catch on, you know,
演唱会和戏剧，因为它们使用相同的技术，对吧？我的意思是，我认为360度全景摄像机出现得太早了。就像，他们尝试过了。每个人都想做，你知道，硅谷必须假装某样东西会流行起来，你知道，
in the next year in order to keep their stock up. And then, you know, maybe one of 10 of those things lasts, but that was kind of the promise of those 360 cameras that as long as you had the ball with the 360 camera, anywhere you went, somebody could interact with, like it was a completely virtual space as long as they had VR. And none of it was quite there, but we maybe go back to that place in a professional situation.
在下一年，以维持他们的股价。然后，也许十个里面有一个能持续下去，但这就是那些360度摄像机的承诺，只要你有那个球形摄像机，无论你去哪里，只要有VR，任何人都可以互动，就像一个完全虚拟的空间。没有一个完全达到那个程度，但我们可能会在专业情况下回到那个位置。
I don't know that it ever catches on for, I don't really ever want to know what's happening, you know, behind the podcaster that I'm watching, you know, like sometimes, you know, the 19 by 10 aspect ratio is just all you need for things like a movie so that's a i think that's a very salient point right is again sometimes the technology becomes the tail wagging the dog when it's like this does not serve the experience especially when the technology is propping up the shareholder value of you know some exactly thing thing. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. Do you see, you see any like red herrings, false paths, places where people are pretending or kind of connect to pan out that are not really, you know, real or you don't feel like, or, or, I never really think about like betting on something to fail because usually that's a recipe for disaster in an environment where like people are constantly investing more and more into everything and pushing things like further and further. Um, because like, for instance, the, the AR like things like would be something that some people might say is a gimmick and is doomed to fail. But I think a better way to look at it is it's not ready yet for primetime.
我不知道它是否会流行起来，我真的不想知道我正在观看的播客主身后发生了什么，你知道，有时19比10的宽高比就是电影所需要的全部。所以我认为这是一个非常切中要点的观点，即有时技术会成为“尾巴摇狗”，当它不能服务于体验时，特别是当技术在支撑某些东西的股东价值时。是的。我不知道。你看到任何红鲱鱼、错误的路径、人们假装或试图连接但并没有真正实现的地方吗？或者我从来没有想过赌某事会失败，因为通常在人们不断投资并推动事物发展的环境中，这往往是灾难的根源。因为，例如，AR之类的东西，有些人可能会说是噱头，注定会失败。但我认为更好的看法是，它还没有准备好进入黄金时段。
But I don't think there's anything that without enough time and attention to it, that's not going to find a niche somewhere in the in the market um that someone's not going to be able to do something cool and amazing with it like i think that just everything is sort of brimming with potential in this moment um and maybe that's kind of a rose-colored view of it i'm sure there's people out there that would uh uh turn up their nose at that idea and say like no there's lots of things they're gimmicks and um and they're probably not gonna pan out but off the top of my head i can't think of anything that i've reacted to lately that i wasn't like oh this is really cool um and has potential um yeah i mean as far as like visual effects and polish i mean i think all of that stuff it's inevitable it's how do you do it in a way that works well? I mean, the stuff that scares me, not just now, but in any era,
但我认为没有什么东西，只要有足够的时间和关注，不能在市场上找到一席之地。总有人能用它做出很酷、很棒的事情。我认为此刻一切都充满了潜力。也许这是一种玫瑰色的看法，我相信外面有人会对此嗤之以鼻，说“不，有很多东西是噱头，它们可能不会成功”。但我脑子里想不出最近有什么让我反应是“哦，这真的很酷”且有潜力的东西。是的，就视觉特效和润色而言，我认为这一切都是不可避免的。问题是如何以一种有效的方式去做？我的意思是，让我害怕的东西，不仅是现在，在任何时代，
is when you're getting rid of the writer. Like, so many of the problems that Hollywood has had, it just comes back to, like, write a script that's good before you do the movie. And when there's just, you know, eight hours of whirlwind and hurricane and, you know, Optimus, and then nothing happens. And that's the kind of filmmaking that I don't like that.
都是当你摆脱编剧的时候。好莱坞遇到的很多问题，归根结底就是：在拍电影之前写一个好剧本。当只有八个小时的旋风、飓风、擎天柱，然后什么都没发生时。那是我不喜欢的电影制作方式。
I feel like it's bad for culture. You know, it's like Marvel movies and a lot of stuff, they get flack, but I was just kind of like, yeah, but somebody made a plan, like not just for the movie that they were making and spending $200
我觉得这对文化有害。你知道，漫威电影和很多东西，它们受到抨击，但我当时只是觉得，是的，但有人制定了计划，不仅是为了他们正在制作并花费2亿美元的电影，而是为了连续五部电影。就像，你知道，是的，也许这不是，
million on, but for five movies in a row, like, you know, like, yeah, maybe this is not, you know,
达芬奇之类的，但我一直在恳求行业在按下录制键之前写好剧本。出于某种原因，我们15年来都做不到这一点。是的，我认为对这些概念采取长远的眼光是。
Leonardo da Vinci or something, but I've just been begging the industry to just write a script before they hit record, you know? And for some reason we couldn't do that for 15 years. Like, yeah, I think that the taking the long view on any of these like concepts is
确定什么可能具有持久力，什么需要经过大量演变才能达到同样水平的绝对方法。而比任何其他东西更能把人们带回来的，不是制作质量、酷炫技术或视觉特效。
definitely the way to identify what probably has some staying power versus what's going to need to go through a lot of evolution before it gets that same. And the, the, the thing that's always going to bring people back more than anything else is not the production, you know, quality or the cool tech or the VFX,
这绝对是判断哪些东西具有持久生命力，而哪些东西在达到同样效果前还需要经历大量演变的方法。而且，最能吸引人们反复回来的东西，永远不是制作质量、炫酷的技术或视觉特效。
like that'll attract some people, right. That are like in it for that but that at the end of the day it's that good story that immersive like experience that you can connect to and resonate with uh that is what people want to spend their money to go be a part of well and i think that's why the script is not um the story in a way that a lot of people make it i mean i like writing and i talk more about kind of like plot structure and things but i mean something like blade runner the first one the the set is telling you the story i mean you're walking
这确实会吸引一些人，对吧。那些对此感兴趣的人，但归根结底，真正能让人愿意花钱去参与的，是那个好故事，那种能让你产生共鸣的沉浸式体验。我觉得这就是为什么剧本不仅仅是很多人所理解的那种“故事”。我的意思是，我喜欢写作，也谈论过很多关于情节结构之类的事情，但像《银翼杀手》第一部那样，场景本身就在为你讲述故事。你走在其中，看到三层场景叠加在一起，世界就是这样，他们曾有过理想化的未来，但后来失败了，现在因为梦想破灭而被改造。哈里森·福特并没有走来走去告诉你：“哦，在未来的50年代，我们以为汽车会有大尾翼，我们很乐观，但后来70年代发生了，太空70年代……”没有人会那样做，是场景在告诉你这一切，这就是为什么设计在叙事中如此重要，而这一点我们往往会忽略。
through it and you're seeing there's three layers of set built on top of each other and the world was this and they had this idealistic future and then it didn't work out and now it's being retrofitted because the dream fell apart and harrison ford's not walking around telling you you know like well in the 50s of the future we thought big fins on cars and we were optimistic but then the 70s happened in the space 70s and like no one's doing any of that it's that you're being told that by a set which is why design is important and part of storytelling in a way that i think we forget yeah absolutely yeah and environmental storytelling as it were maybe escape rooms too maybe that's the the next frontier. So, Oh, I, uh,
是的，绝对是这样。环境叙事也是如此，也许密室逃脱也是下一个前沿领域。所以，哦，我，呃，
uh, Hmm. You've got some ideas there. Well, so escape rooms, I think. So for a while, of course I lived in Orlando, uh,
呃，嗯。你有一些想法。嗯，关于密室逃脱，我想是这样。有一段时间，我当然住在奥兰多，呃，
which maybe had like a glut of escape rooms, uh, in the like pre pandemic moment, like 20, 20, like 16 to 2019. I feel like there was a new social distance by locking yourself in a room with 12 people yeah so that maybe uh hampered the the growth of the escape room
那里在疫情前，比如2016年到2019年，可能密室逃脱过剩了。我觉得当时有一种新的社交距离方式，就是把自己和12个人锁在一个房间里。是的，所以这可能稍微阻碍了密室逃脱行业的发展，
industry a little bit but it didn't slow down much to be completely honest because i went back recently and um it still felt like there's an escape room on every corner. But they are. They're getting them and turning them into axe throwing. It really does feel like the local business boom bus cycle is just like somebody spinning a dial. Now it's frozen yogurt. Now it's cupcakes that are weird flavors. Now it's axes like yeah pulling words out of a hat and being like okay this is the new experiential uh installation that we're gonna do vango projection
但老实说，并没有放缓多少，因为我最近回去看了一下，嗯，感觉每个角落依然都有密室逃脱。但它们正在被改造，变成了投斧游戏。当地商业的繁荣与萧条周期真的感觉就像有人在转动转盘。现在是冷冻酸奶，现在是口味奇怪的纸杯蛋糕，现在是投斧。就像从帽子里抽词一样，说：“好吧，这就是我们要做的新的体验式装置。”梵高投影
experiences uh oh yeah that's that's a little bit bigger than the small business but you know the like i don't know is yogurt by the pounds still a thing? I think all of ours closed. Oh, yeah. We've got one here near my house now. It goes decent on high foot traffic days. Tastes good. But escape rooms, I think, actually have the opportunity to implement a lot of very cool technologies that don't scale well but create a very like interesting immersive experience on like a on that micro level on which they operate where it's like you can have you know arduinos and raspberry pies like these small microcontroller elements that are like smart like devices that suddenly become keys or clues or like things that you can like interact with and touch and hold uh and that's
体验，哦，是的，那比小企业规模大一点，但你知道，我不知道按磅计价的酸奶现在还流行吗？我想我们这边的都关门了。哦，是的。我住的地方附近现在还有一家。在人流量大的日子里生意还不错。味道很好。但我认为，密室逃脱实际上有机会实施许多非常酷的技术，这些技术虽然无法大规模扩展，但在其运营的微观层面上创造了一种非常有趣的沉浸式体验。比如你可以使用Arduino和树莓派，这些小型微控制器元件就像智能设备，突然变成了钥匙、线索或你可以互动、触摸和持有的东西，这
a completely different kind of like experiential art that uses technology in a completely different way than like the macro scale of a 10 000 person concert now it's like you're making an experience for 12 people and it's much more intimate and like the things that you can do there are so cool um and and fun to like execute and i get really into the tech of it even though i think that there's been like maybe too many people trying to do it all at once um but that you know fast like the things you can do with like a maglock and an infrared chip are pretty spectacular on that like 12 person you know in a room kind of scale well i think that that is uh kind of why the failure of disney's like star cruiser galactic star cruiser hotel
是一种完全不同类型的体验艺术，它使用技术的方式与万人演唱会的宏观规模完全不同。现在你是在为12个人创造体验，它更私密，你在那里能做的事情非常酷，而且执行起来很有趣。我真的很沉迷于其中的技术，尽管我认为可能太多人试图同时做这件事了。但你知道，在12人一间的规模下，用磁力锁和红外芯片能做的事情非常壮观。嗯，我认为这就是迪士尼“星际巡洋舰”酒店失败的原因，
thing i mean the people made a lot of noise about the price but what i kept seeing i mean i didn't go to anything like that but what i kept seeing was that it was like that you could see sort of like cyberpunk all of these things that had been started in development as really cool concepts that can immerse you and then sort of not executed and abandoned. So you saw half of, you know, a hundred good ideas and none of it really was telling you the story that they were trying to tell you. Yeah.
我的意思是，人们对价格议论纷纷，但我一直看到的是——我没去过那种地方——但我一直看到的是，你可以看到赛博朋克等所有这些最初作为非常酷的概念开发的东西，最终没有执行好并被放弃了。所以你看到了半个，你知道，一百个好点子，但没有一个真正讲述了他们试图讲述的故事。是的。
I, um, uh, by the time star cruiser was open, I think I had already moved on. Um, and of course never got a chance to go because so much of when it was open was like through pandemic era and then we were like busy
我，嗯，呃，到星际巡洋舰开业时，我想我已经不再关注了。嗯，当然也没机会去，因为开业期间大部分时间都在疫情期间，然后我们很忙，
and that wasn't something that I was like uh I couldn't get away from or find like a block of time when I was like this is the chance to go do this and then all of a sudden it's closing and I was like well I guess I missed my shot um But conceptually, right, like they were totally keyed into the idea of immersion. They were really going to like put you in it for maybe to a fault. Like, I don't know. It's hard to say that like, you know, maybe the ambition was like more than technically possible to execute but i think there are a lot of really good ideas that went into it that we'll probably see again that's why i mentioned escape rooms with movies and concerts is i kind of wonder if eventually you don't see these experience
那不是我能抽身或者找到时间去的地方，当时我想：“这就是去体验的机会。”然后突然它就关闭了，我想：“好吧，我想我错过了机会。”但从概念上讲，他们完全抓住了沉浸感的精髓。他们真的打算让你身临其境，甚至可能有点过头了。我不知道。很难说这种雄心是否超过了技术上可执行的范围，但我认为其中包含了很多非常好的想法，我们可能会再次看到。这就是为什么我提到密室逃脱、电影和演唱会，我很好奇最终是否会看到这些体验
technologies coherent to something like that i mean is that's not really a hotel it's not really a theme park it's not really a movie you know It's not really a movie. It's not really a concert, but it is kind of being dropped into a completely virtual space that is also somewhat analog. Right. It's absolutely telling you a story and you are the driver of the narrative in that case because you are the character and your goal is to escape. It's a straightforward motivation but like there are so many cool twists and turns that it can take as you like go on that that process so let's do it let's make westworld um that that ended well right oh
技术融合在一起。我的意思是，那不是真正的酒店，不是真正的主题公园，也不是真正的电影。你知道，它不是真正的电影。它不是真正的演唱会，但它确实像是被扔进了一个既是虚拟又有点模拟的空间。没错。它绝对是在讲故事，而在那种情况下，你是叙事的驱动者，因为你是角色，你的目标是逃脱。这是一个直接的动机，但当你经历那个过程时，它可以有许多酷炫的转折。所以我们来做吧，让我们制造“西部世界”。那个结局很好，对吧？哦，
yeah yeah yeah there's nothing that could possibly go wrong because and we've got all the pieces now because we've got ai we've got you know humanoid robots we've got uh cool interactive tech that we can give to people and ways to record their every like thought and motion as they uh make their way through the story so like let's just put them all together and watch the you get iconic scenes where uh yule brinner uh says unfortunately i'm a large language model and my database only goes back to 2023. Right. Yeah.
是的，是的，是的，不可能出什么差错，因为我们现在拥有了所有组件：我们有人工智能，我们有类人机器人，我们有酷炫的交互技术可以给人们，还有记录他们每一个想法和动作的方法，当他们穿过故事时。所以，让我们把它们放在一起，看着你得到标志性的场景，尤尔·伯连纳说：“不幸的是，我是一个大型语言模型，我的数据库只更新到2023年。”没错。是的。
My safety programming doesn't allow me to engage in this conversation any further. Please try, you know, reframing. I'm sorry, Hal. You need to subscribe to chat GPT-4 for $20 a month. You have run out of interactions with this robot for today please uh please upgrade your subscription well uh i appreciate you getting together do you want
“我的安全程序不允许我继续参与此对话。请尝试，你知道，重新表述。”“对不起，哈尔。你需要每月支付20美元订阅ChatGPT-4。你今天与该机器人的互动次数已用尽，请升级您的订阅。”嗯，我很感谢你能来。你想
to um tell us about any you want to pitch anything or tell us about the company that you work with or the opportunities that they offer uh anything we don't get to you feel like is is a important thing to hit on oh uh no i was mostly just here to chat today right like uh it's um it's just great to be on and great to like talk about some of this stuff and i'm always super interested in kind of the the psychology underpinning um how we make these decisions and and how we create experiences for each other. So it's like, it's cool to come on and sort of do the reverse, right. Where we talk about the technology of how we do it.
嗯，告诉我们任何你想推销的东西，或者告诉我们你工作的公司，或者他们提供的机会，任何我们没谈到但你觉得很重要的事情吗？哦，呃，没有，我今天主要是来聊天的。对吧，就像，能来这里谈论这些事情真是太棒了，我一直对支撑我们如何做出这些决定以及我们如何为彼此创造体验的心理学非常感兴趣。所以，能来这里进行反向交流，谈论我们如何实现这些技术的背后逻辑，真的很酷。
And I hope that this can kind of like inform, you know, as you're going forward in the series, like, you know, how you think about the other aspects of this that aren't the tech that are the creative and are the like writing and thoughts that go into um yeah experiences and it's it's hard to get like the technology the psychology and the technology of filmmaking is is interesting um you know it's easy to talk about the kind of like psychology of like the artist the process of like writing or something but some parts of filmmaking are so hard to get into like um always like roger deakins has a podcast the cinematographer and he like talks a lot with his
我希望这能在你接下来的系列节目中提供一些参考，比如你如何思考除了技术之外的其他方面，即创意、写作以及投入到体验中的想法。是的，很难掌握电影制作的心理学和技术，这很有趣。谈论艺术家的心理、写作过程等很容易，但电影制作的某些部分很难深入。比如，罗杰·狄金斯有一档播客，他是摄影指导，他经常和他的
wife on there but there's like not anything that would ever let you learn his process because it's so intuitive that he's just like yeah sometimes you want to use a really wide lens but other times you do this but you know like when i see a color i can tell you you know within like a teeny tiny fraction of a possibility exactly the chemical composition that kodak used to pull that color out how many stops it is of whatever but it's just like he's so incredibly technical um right very naturalistically that there's not really he's never he's just not the cinematographer that is going to be like oh and you use the 16 millimeter and you push it forward slowly you feel like you're flying and that creates a dream like like he just doesn't think that way you know right it's it's very much something that's like baked into how he sees the world
妻子在上面交谈，但没有任何东西能让你学到他的过程，因为这太直觉了。他只是说：“是的，有时你想用非常广的镜头，但有时你会这样做。”但你知道，当我看到一种颜色时，我可以告诉你，在极小的误差范围内，柯达用来提取那种颜色的化学成分，它是多少档光圈等等。但他就是如此极其技术化，非常自然地，他从来不是那种会说：“哦，你用16毫米胶片，慢慢向前推进，你会感觉自己在飞，这创造了一种梦幻般的感觉”的摄影师。他根本不那样思考，你知道，这非常像是融入了他看待世界的方式。
yeah reactions to the world around you and the stimulus and it's like that's what you you know it's your own intuition that you use to drive you and create it you just hope that it resonates with other he never mentions it like he doesn't bring it up but the guests that he's had on have said things like that like when they redid fargo he told them that their film stock had degraded because the color of the sweatshirt was like the wrong kind of brown and they were like no we've double checked it and he was like no it's wrong and they're like you haven't seen this for 25 years and he's like it's just not right and then they saw that like one chemical had been messed up you can see the difference in like 1 16th of a stop of light you like you can tell if there's a shutter leak you know because one of the blades of your you know
是的，对周围世界的反应和刺激，这就是你用来驱动和创造的直觉，你只是希望它能引起别人的共鸣。他从不提及这一点，他不会主动提起，但他邀请过的嘉宾说过类似的话。比如当他们重拍《冰血暴》时，他告诉他们胶片退化了，因为运动衫的颜色是错误的棕色。他们说：“不，我们核对过了。”他说：“不，它是错的。”他们说：“你已经25年没见过这个了。”他说：“就是不对。”然后他们发现确实有一种化学成分搞错了。你可以看出1/16档光圈的差异，你可以看出是否有漏光，你知道，因为你的超定焦镜头中的一片叶片
ultra primes is not right you know yeah i wonder if, if people that have that sort of like almost extra sensory ability, I wonder if they have like some mild form of like synesthesia where they're like, not just seeing it, but like. Something is filtered out. Yeah. Because it has to bother them.
不对，你知道。是的，我很好奇，如果人们拥有那种近乎超感官的能力，我不知道他们是否有一种轻微的联觉，不仅仅是看到它，而是……某种东西被过滤掉了。是的。因为它一定会困扰他们。
You know, you don't, we don't dedicate resources to things that don't cause us anxiety. And so, you know, that's, I think that's so much of under the creative processes. You've seen the same thing so many times. You don't cause us anxiety and so you know that's i think that's so much of under the creative process is you've seen the same thing so many times you don't like it you feel anxious about
你知道，我们不会把资源投入到不会引起我们焦虑的事情上。所以，我认为这就是创作过程的很大一部分。你已经看过同样的东西很多次了。它不会引起你的焦虑，所以你知道，我认为这就是创作过程的很大一部分，你已经看过同样的东西很多次了，你不喜欢它，你感到焦虑，
it and then you innovate and yeah same way he's being bothered by that you know the film grain is not perfect you know yeah you see you just see it but then it's like you're not seeing that it's wrong it's like you're feeling that it's wrong. Yeah. It's very interesting way. Well, I really appreciate you coming on today. It's great to talk to you. Um, we have to, you're like any,
然后你进行创新。是的，同样地，他被那个困扰，你知道胶片颗粒不完美，你知道，是的，你只是看到了，但并不是你看到它是错的，而是你感觉到它是错的。是的。这是一种非常有趣的方式。好吧，非常感谢你今天能来。和你聊天很棒。嗯，我们必须，你就像任何
a lot of people that have a topic that's so broad, maybe we can do it again with, um, something else. And, you know, technology will probably be totally different in a couple of years, but anywhere people can go,
很多话题太广泛的人一样，也许我们可以再做一次，谈谈别的东西。而且，你知道，几年后技术可能会完全不同，但人们可以去任何地方，
if they want to check out anything that you, even if it's just something you recommend that, um, you know, resources for people interested in, in jumping off points from anything we talked about today. Oh, yeah,
如果他们想查看你推荐的任何东西，即使只是你推荐的资源，对于那些对我们今天谈论的任何话题感兴趣的人来说，作为跳板。哦，是的，
I would totally, if you're interested in this kind of like world and like, and the kinds of things that are possible, like as a creator, you may, you probably already know about it, but I would highly recommend downloading like blender as a 3d like creative tool i would check out something like unreal engine which is uh free for um small
我绝对会，如果你对这种世界以及作为创作者可能实现的事情感兴趣，你可能已经知道了，但我强烈建议下载像Blender这样的3D创作工具。我会看看像虚幻引擎这样的东西，它对小型
create like small creators people with revenue under like a million dollars uh can just download the engine and tool around with it and have a lot of like cool templates and stuff and it's like there's and an unreal engine is a video game engine but it's also you know they have this entire workflow for creatives for doing like film and live production and things like that and you can see it um yeah they i think they have like case studies and things on their website the epic games of like different cool things that they've been a part of um so that's where i would start if you're interested in like the future of where live real time environment design is going in,
创作者，比如收入在一百万美元以下的人是免费的，他们可以直接下载引擎并尝试使用，里面有很多酷炫的模板之类的。而且虚幻引擎是一个视频游戏引擎，但它也是，你知道，他们有整个针对创作者的工作流程，用于电影和现场制作等。你可以看到它，是的，我想他们的Epic Games网站上有案例研究，关于他们参与过的不同酷炫项目。所以如果你对实时环境设计的未来感兴趣，这就是我会开始的地方，
in concert to film for sure. Well, cool. Yeah. Thank you so much. And if you, if there's like, I can look and put a link to some of that stuff in the show notes.
无论是演唱会还是电影，肯定是的。好吧，太酷了。是的，非常感谢。如果可以的话，我可以找找看，把其中一些东西的链接放在节目说明里。
Yeah. But yeah, I appreciate you coming on and Andy Philpo. Thank you so much. Hey, thanks Joe. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。但无论如何，感谢你来参加，安迪·菲尔波。非常感谢。嘿，谢谢乔。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。